welcome to soundtrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
is it possible that firefly the greatest
tv show ever made is actually getting a
reboot
let's have a look at the story
[Music]
[Music]
so it's about seven months ago giant
freaking robot first broke this story an
exclusive they say they have an insider
at disney and has told them firefly is
most definitely 100 percent getting a
reboot
but then it all went very quiet for six
months
then disney had their big shareholders
meeting
a plethora of new projects was announced
but no firefly so does that mean giant
freaking robot lied to us
well now they say and they've doubled
down a bit here that no
the tv show is most definitely in the
works
the reboot is in development but it's at
a stage far too early yet to be released
to the public
so did you freaking robot lie about this
is there no insider did they make it all
up
there's a special place for people that
lie about the firefly tv show
the special hell
so what does this mean and do we even
want firefly back in our screens so do i
want to see it first of all
firefly is one of my favorite tv shows
since its reappearance of disney plus
i've watched it about three times
including the movies
it's a brilliant show
but
it was very much character driven
um um
i'll spare you the boring details
falling in with untrustworthy folk
making a bunch of bad calls
all that matters is i expect to be
shuffled off and
you two are the only people i trust to
get me where i'm going
uh which
[Music]
this show shouldn't have worked it had
no budget the basic premise of cowboys
in space was kind of stupid
even though the set of the actual
firefly was beautifully built i mean
josh sweden insisted on actually like
building it so that you could walk
through it so you can walk from the
bridge
through the crew quarters down into the
decks the shuttle bays you could you
could physically walk through the ship
all the way through and i think that
i don't ever remember that really being
done on a tv show before but
with the budget with cowboys in space
with everything else it shouldn't have
worked but it did and why did it work it
mainly worked because of the characters
you know people watch firefly and they
think
boy you guys must have a lot of fun
there you must have a great time the
hijinks that ensue
well the truth is
there are no hijinks we're absolutely
serious we're very professional and we
never
ever make mistakes
i'll turn this [ __ ] thing off
nathan fillion is mal
jane
wash
river simon they all were brilliant
each of them brought something different
they very much had like a family feel to
the series and that really reflected in
their off-screen antics
that's right
one of our bandits had family ties
who's a daughter can i just step into
that again
[Music]
fly right on my nose
they did become great friends
alan tudyk and nathan fillion in
particular are really really good
friends off screen that is the problem
is that the characters made the show and
the characters let's be honest aren't
going to return
alan tudyk for me would have been the
obvious one to return for a reboot
i personally love alien resident though
and i want that to come back so i
wouldn't necessarily want him to return
to a firefly series anyway
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
but they killed him in serenity anyway
so he's not coming back
nathan fillion probably would come back
we all love that scene from castle where
he comes down as halloween and what do
you what are you dressed as dad
space cowboy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
hey
i was i was just
trying on my halloween costume what
exactly are you supposed to be
space cowboy
[Music]
we all love that scene
and it just shows his love for the show
but also around 89 years ago he was
asked at an interview if you won sort of
like the state lottery the 100 million
quid what would you do with it and his
answer was without missing a beat
i'd buy the rights to firefly
and they're sort of asking what would
you do and he had story ideas he had
plot lines he had everything planned out
on what he would do with the firefly
series if he owned it if he could return
so actually would
he come back to firefly
he'd probably love to
but his series the rookie is doing
really well
he's very committed to that series
and no nathan philly won't be returning
could he return as an executive producer
or something along those lines though oh
hell yeah you know he'd run at that
and particularly if they did short runs
you know like 10 10 episodes so i think
it would be really a project of love for
him and i think that could happen yes
mal
it would boost the signal
but even if some passerby did happen to
receive all it would do is knocked out
the kafka
this is all very doable
there are characters i think that could
return i don't see any reason why river
and simon couldn't come back and
actually i could sort of guess a longer
storyline they were so integral to the
initial storyline that i could actually
see that that would make sense that they
could maybe bring that into the reboot
there is also a possibility obviously
that they just do a complete reboot they
ignore the original series and movie
and just
start again
that probably is the only way this is
going to work
and there's been such a big gap
the story was so
you could never see mal giving up the
fireflies if they want the actual
firefly in the new series they're gonna
have to it would have been like over his
dead body sort of thing
so um from a storyline point of view you
can never see that
they could basically start again as well
with the whole
story and actually tell it the way joss
whedon intended to initially i would
like to see some changes if they do do
that for one one of the things i really
enjoyed about the original series was
the this idea that the american and
chinese
cultures are the prominent cultures
they're the ones that are like dominant
within this new society
that's how they got away with all the
swearing they did in chinese the census
didn't get it you know um
but they never actually had any chinese
people in the show
if you're going to have a basic premise
of that follow through you know actually
follow through and actually do it
and it was always a bit half-hearted so
i'd like to see that as a change
i would obviously like to see a better
budget
and i'd like to see the cowboys and
space thing toned down a little bit i
think that turned people off it turned
me off
this is one of my favorite shows but i
never actually watched it first time
around because i just thought it looked
stupid my point here is would disney
even want this show to come back
well there are massive risks but massive
rewards
disney plus had desperately trying to
compete with netflix and one of the ways
they have to compete is by content they
need
content
[Music]
[Applause]
it was one of the big problems of disney
plus when it first started there was
nothing on it it was only really when
they bought fox and moved all a lot of
the fox material on that all of a sudden
you had a stream service with lots and
lots of choices
before that it was marvel old disney
films or
star wars that was it you don't really
have any other choices netflix has been
spending billions on content for years
they know that that's the way to get
people streaming
get something and exciting get an
exciting project something that people
are going to go yeah i'm going to
subscribe and then a lot of people never
unsubscribe
so this could be another way disney
could do that
get a bit of buzz bring back an old
favorite
you have
a ready-made audience there will be
millions of us brown coats there ready
to watch this show
a ready-made audience
but there's a downside to that
we really love this show i mean we
really love this show
they're gonna have to do something
that's completely different in some ways
because we're going to compare it
it's i don't know when the star trek the
next generation series first came out
people hated it
they thought it was sacrilege they
thought it was a tv show stomping on the
grave of the old one the show that they
loved most
and there's going to be a similar
backlash and that was before the time
the internet
i'm you know and social media imagine
the uproar now when this does get
announced people are going to be really
pissed off
i'm not sure people are going to be a
lot of people aren't going to be happy
about it
and
they're going to be very worried that
they're going to ruin the original show
one way for disney to get away with that
though is to have enough separation and
they're quite good now at making these
reboots and these prequels and things
disney are the masters of it you know
and that's why i think it'll be a
complete reboot where they basically
ignore the original show and maybe just
have little references it every so often
to make us happy so would joss whedon
return to this tv series
to be honest i don't think he would i
think disney
would try to keep joss whedon at arm's
length ten years ago following avengers
joss whedon was hot property that's one
of the reasons why we got the serenity
film was because he was basically asked
by universal what do you want to do and
he went serenity film
but since then his career has maybe
taken a bit of a nosedive
he stepped away from the nevers a tv
show i actually really enjoyed
and we don't really know why
he
ruined the justice league movie
and there have been several accusations
of bullying
charisma carpenter said that the
bullying during the series of
angel and buffy the vampire slayer was
so bad
it made her not want to be in the acting
business and it actually has affected
her even in later life
even jason momoa a guy that i wouldn't
suspect is a clever idea to bully him
has said that joss whedon was a bit of a
prat on set
james masters who played spike said that
at one point joss whedon had hoped
against a wall screaming at him so the
joss reading the name at the moment
isn't exactly
the what it was a few years ago and it
has been dragged through the mud a
little bit
i don't think disney would want him
anywhere near the tv show and to honest
i hope he doesn't if this show is going
to work it's going to need to be new
it's going to need to be fresh
so let's see what disney plus do with
the greatest tv show ever made
please like subscribe if you're new to
the channel which you are because it's a
new channel and leave me a comment do
you want to see firefly return even if
you know it's going to have to be a
complete reboot and completely new if we
do see an original character return
which character do you want to see
and
do you actually believe this is even
true
thanks very much and uh
[Music]